-Our next guest has worked
in politics and public service
as an aide and advisor
to Hillary Rodham Clinton
during her two presidential
campaigns, as well as her time
as First Lady, Senator,
and Secretary of State.
Her Memoir "Both/And: A Life in
Many Worlds" is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show
Huma Abedin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you for having me,
I'm so excited.
-You've been here before
in the green room
when Hillary has been a guest
on the show.
And now you are on camera,
you are on -- in studio.
You've been doing a lot of press
for your book tour.
How are you adjusting to being
the focus of attention?
-I still walk backstage
and then keep looking behind me
for Hillary.
Because assuming that's who
you're expecting to talk to,
and then realize I have to go
out and say words.
And I wrote many words,
and now I'm saying many words,
and I'm having a great time.
-I've got to be honest,
you're a natural.
You're a natural with the words.
-Seth, we have been here I think
at least five times.
-I think that's right.
-Me with Hillary.
And I'm usually a little bit
more productive.
Because usually when you guys
are out here,
I'm back there ordering
Seamless,
figuring out what I'm going
to have for dinner,
getting on a conference call.
-Sure.
-So I actually have
a conference call in my ear
on one side and talking to you.
-While we're having this
conversation.
I bet you're probably pretty
good at that sorta multitasking.
-Multitasking. There's a lot of
multitasking in this book.
-So I have to ask --
you know, this book is about
how you grew up,
and it's about your time
with Hillary.
It's also about
your personal life,
which was incredibly traumatic.
And, you know, it's very raw.
The details of this book.
Was it traumatic reliving it?
Or was it cathartic
putting it down on paper?
-You know, this ended up
being --
I hadn't thought about it
in the moment,
but it did end up being
a COVID pandemic book.
I really -- it forced me,
being in one place and space,
sitting and writing.
And I thought it would be
really hard,
but I basically just poured
my heart into the story.
And I found it to be
incredible therapy.
I loved the writing process.
I rediscovered what it was like
to write --
my father always thought I would
be a writer when I grew up.
He always told me
the greatest power I held
was in the power of my pen,
if I used it wisely.
And so I loved it.
And I feel it as I'm out in the
world, the sense of liberation.
-Also, you know, you have
this very public marriage
to someone, Anthony Weiner.
And you know,
we all sort of in real time
are experiencing
what's happening.
Has it sort of, writing this
book, brought down the walls
in a way that people now feel
that they can approach you,
even people that were maybe
close to you
that didn't want to have
these conversations
or didn't know if you were
willing to have them.
Have you been able to talk
to people more about it,
having written the book?
-You know, Seth, in 2011
when the story first broke
about Anthony,
and I was not even
12 weeks pregnant,
I'm working at
the State Department --
it was the first time
I realized -- I mean, you know,
you and I started
this conversation,
that I'm used to being
behind the scenes,
used to being the person not
talked about, being invisible,
and I really liked that.
And that very first trip I took,
I was at an airport,
and a woman comes over and she
puts her arm on my arm
in the bathroom while
I'm washing my hands and says,
"I know what you're going
through, hang in there."
And that was the first of
what I would say is hundreds,
thousands, maybe, of moments
in the last decade
where people have approached me
on the street.
I've been at dinner parties, at
restaurants, and somebody will
come over and say, "Can I talk
to you for a second?"
And we step outside
and it's almost like
these little group
mini therapy sessions.
And if that's a service that
I can -- if that's one thing...
I try to believe that
there's a silver lining
to everything that happens
in our lives.
And so if I can share,
I'm happy to do it.
And it's been -- it's been
a wonderful connection
with strangers.
-I'm so glad that you are
getting that from the experience
of writing the book.
You talk about giving back and
hoping that this, you know,
can provide a service to people.
There's some very funny things
that you've had to do
over the course of your career
working for Hillary Clinton.
The one that
I would not have predicted
is having to fish a dress
out of the East River.
-You know, so I have
a lot of friends
who now work
in the Biden administration.
And the young ones would call me
and say,
"How do I train, what do I do,
and how did you know...?"
Because I was a 21-year-old
when I walked into the Clinton
White House in 1996.
I had no idea.
I mean, it was a total
sink-or-swim attitude there.
And I think in part, that was
part of the training.
You know, it was,
let's just see how she does.
And the very first trip
I took with the President
and First Lady
to New York City on Marine One,
I did not know
that when a president traveled
there's more than one
helicopter.
I'm on the staff helicopter
with all the luggage.
The helicopter lands.
I take all the luggage off.
My helicopter takes off
as Marine One is landing.
And the prop wash lifts the
First Lady's clothes,
the hanging bag,
off the landing zone
and it flings it
into the East River.
So I have to figure out
what to do. I run inside.
This guy comes out with a broom,
and he's like, "This has never
happened in all my years."
Take this sopping-wet bag,
put it in the car,
figure out how to get it
dry cleaned.
She walked on stage the next
morning to give a speech,
12 hours later, she had no idea
her clothes were floating
in the East River.
-Wow, that's amazing.
-And I didn't tell --
I didn't tell her that story
for a long time.
It was like five years.
-I mean, that --
what an advertisement
for any dry cleaner
that can get --
if you can get the East River
out of a dress.
-They did well, they did well.
-They did well.
You obviously, over the years,
gave Hillary a lot of feedback
on things like speeches.
-Yeah.
-Did she have any feedback
on this?
Did you present it to her?
Did you look to her for guidance
in any way?
-She was one of the first people
to read the book.
And she gave me -- her notes
were hysterical.
Because she sent me back
the manuscript,
and in the margins she would
write, "This is very funny."
Like when I tell the story
of her breaking her elbow
and me fainting in the hospital
and peeing in my pants.
And she's -- you know, like --
she's reliving the moments
with me.
But she was just really
encouraging.
Gave me -- she didn't tell me
to cut anything.
Said put whatever was in there.
In fact, I just talked to her
before I came on the show,
and I said, "I'm going
to see Seth,
do you want me to say anything
about you to him?"
She's like, "Oh, just tell him
you love me."
I'm like, "Okay!"
I love my boss, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, congratulations
on the book.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You deserve to be out here.
Get out of the green room, Huma.
-Thanks, Seth.
Thrilled to be on the show.
-Huma Abedin, everyone.
"Both/And: A Life in Many
Worlds" is available now.
Be right back.